fragrant spice rice pudding I love
cooking with spices but you don't have
to just cook save your dishes using
aromatics and spices across desserts
takes your puddings to a completely
different level first off a spices this
is a fresh vanilla pod fragrant and
packed full of flavor use the back of
the knife and flatten it that removes
all those little seeds off the skin of
the vanilla pod take your knife slice
down the middle and then when you open
that up smell is incredible take the tip
of the knife and you scrape inside and
look all those seeds dying to come out
that is incredible there are thousands
of seeds still ingrained to the pod so
put them in the casserole cardamom
powerful spicy take two little pods
place your knife on top lightly crack
them cracking the cardamom pods helps
release all the amazing flavor close
because that kind of aniseed flavor with
a lot of depth one two three cinnamon
stick snap and in just smelling that
level of fragrance you can imagine what
the rice put in the taste-off turn on
the heat lightly toast those spices just
a couple of seconds I was gonna happen
it's just gonna sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
and even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in sugar two tablespoons
milk and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream bring it slowly to the boil to
allow the flavors to infuse and this
rice pudding reminds me of my time in
India where I got really into that chai
tea fragrance because it was just so
delicious and so comforting
take a line in the line just cuts
through the richness of the coconut
gives it that nice little bit of acidity
goes fantastically well with a cinnamon
and that fresh vanilla nice have a taste
hmm now let's go up to the ball give it
a nice little clean around the outside
and in with a rice use 200 grams of
pudding rice don't wash it beforehand
because the starch helps thicken the
rice pudding in the oven and just turn
that down to a light simmer and the
pudding rice starts to open up and it
absorbs all that coconut vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out for
three to five minutes boiling it rapidly
the rice opens up and it goes into mush
we'll want to keep that nice texture
that sort of fragrant rice pudding on a
gentle simmer
next a little luxury I will show you how
I take this simple delicious aromatic
rice pudding to a completely different
level here's what I do take two egg
yolks
separate them now give that a really
nice whisk to nice tablespoons of
mascarpone cheese whisk that into the
egg yolks just as nice and smooth it's
almost like finishing the rice pudding
and a delicious custard turn off the gas
add that into the rice pudding and what
happens it starts to enrich and really
thicken this rice pudding and takes it
to a completely different level the rice
is still not cooked start to get nice
and soft you can just see how it's
opening up but look it's like rich
aromatic lava bubbling away finally
great more citrus zest the lime on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
the rice pudding is phenomenal then put
it in the other 15 minutes at 200
degrees to finish cooking the rice and
develop the intensely aromatic flavors
look at that an incredibly fragrant rice
pudding how beautiful is that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
yeah the beef start placing it around
your salad saffron is the most expensive
spice in the world made from the dried
stigma of crocus flowers